jonathan viene de mal metí en bélgica y
ha recorrido en 1500 kilómetros para
llegar a médica en su camión agua
pañales leche juguetes y peluches
ya tenía en mente la idea de hacer algo
tal vez no venir de golf pero sí
participar activamente era evidente así
que que estamos y como tengo tres hijos
hicimos el convoy especialmente para los
niños
antes de partir fue a ver a los
comerciantes de su pueblo todos se
reunieron para llenar su camión
fue un chocolatero del pueblo donde vivo
el que nos preparó creo que casi durante
dos noches cajitas de chocolate
especialmente para los niños así que no
empaque todo y su mujer también ha
famoso comentario nuevo jonathan estaba
solo cuando llegó pero rápidamente
conocí a jeremy y nicolás franceses de
libros que habían llegado unas horas
antes en un coche con 400 mantas y
medicinas francamente la solidaridad
aquí es increíble mira hemos hecho una
colaboración franco bell ya tenemos una
mezcla de banderas expuestas así que es
magnífico
christophe es un bombero profesional
viene de niza en francia se tomó un
tiempo libre y fue la frontera
pero si tenemos que ser un poco
humanistas también hay gente cruel por
un lado tenemos que poner la balanza de
nuestro lado casi se avergüenzan un poco
de todo lo que les llevamos son muy
corteses y francamente es agradable ver
algunas sonrisas
y esta ola de solidaridad no va a parar
cada día decenas y decenas de
voluntarios llegan de todo el mundo con
la esperanza de ayudar a los refugiados
ucranianos a su manera